♪ ♪
>> Katie: PRESIDENT BIDEN
GETTING ROLLED BY THE FAR LEFT
WALL HANGING OUT OVERSEAS WITH
THE POPE AND EUROPEAN LEADERS.
PROGRESSIVES REFUSING TO BUDGE
AFTER HIS BIG ANNOUNCEMENT
INTRODUCING A NEW FRAMEWORK FOR
HIS SCALED-BACK BUT STILL
MASSIVE SPENDING AGENDA.
>> NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
AN IOU.
>> OF LUKE BAMBOOZLED.
THIS IS NOT LIKE GOD WAS COMING
TODAY.
>> WE NEED TO KEEP THE PROMISE
THAT WAS MADE.
>> PROGRESSIVES HAVE DONE OUR
WORK AND GETTING EVERYBODY TO A
PLACE WHERE WE ENDORSE THE
FRAMEWORK THAT THE PRESIDENT
LAID OUT.
>> Katie: JESSICA, AS THE DEMO
KITE AT THE TABLE, DO YOU FEEL
BAMBOOZLED BY WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW ON CAPITOL HILL?
>> Jessica: FOR WANTS --
I THINK THERE HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PROGRESS.
TWO WEEKS AGO WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO END UP
WITH THE 1.5 TO $1.7 TRILLION
RANGE.
THAT'S WHAT JOE MANCHIN TOLD
JOE BIDEN HE WAS UP TO.
NOW RO KHANNA, THE WIDTH OF THE
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS, TELLING
NEIL CAVUTO, TEN DAYS IT WILL BE
DONE.
THERE IS A LOT THAT PROGRESSIVES
SHOULD BE HAPPY ABOUT.
I THINK THE ATTITUDE SHOULD BE
VERSUS NOTHING, YOU'RE GETTING A
WHOLE LOT OF SOMETHING.
EVERYONE WILL GET ONBOARD.
NANCY PELOSI DOESN'T MESS UP.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
SHE KNOWS WHERE THE BOUNDARY
LINES ARE.
SHE KNEW WHEN SHE ENDORSE THE
FRAMEWORK THAT IT WAS GOING TO
WORK, AND BIDEN KNEW AS WELL.
HE WAS GOING TO COME BACK TO A
ROSIER PICTURE.
>> Katie: SHANNON, IT WAS
EITHER REALLY GOOD IDEA FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT AND LEAVE AND LET
THEM HASH IT OUT.
OR LOOKS BAD BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE HE'S REALLY INVOLVED
AS THEY CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAPPEN.
>> Shannon: BECAUSE GREG HAS
CHILD CARE ISSUES, THAT'S WHY
GREG JR. IS SITTING WITH ME.
IT'S A HUGE GAMBLE.
YOU REALLY PUT PRESSURE ON YOUR
PARTY BECAUSE YOU'RE LEAVING AND
SAYING I EXPECTED TO BE DONE BY
THE TIME I GET BACK.
THE FIRST WAS BY THE TIME I
LAND.
LIKE YOU SAID, SPEAKER PELOSI
DOESN'T MESS UP IN THE SENSE
THAT SHE'S ALWAYS VERY AWARE OF
WHAT THE WHIP COUNT IS, HER VOTE
COUNT.
SHE'S NOT PUTTING SOMETHING ON
THE FLOOR TO WATCH IT BURST INTO
FLAMES.
WE'LL SEE HOW SHE DOES.
IT PUTS THE SPOTLIGHT ON HOW
MUCH SWAY THE SQUAD DOES OR
DOESN'T HAVE.
THEY LOST A LOT OF WHAT THEY
WANTED IN THE BILL AND THEY ARE
FINDING MAYBE IT'S EASIER TO
CAMPAIGN ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
TICK-TOCK THAN IT IS TO GET
HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
TO AGREE TO ANYTHING.
IT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT OF A
REALITY CHECK.
>> Katie: THERE IS A GAME OF
CHICKEN GOING ON.
PROGRESSIVES ARE HOLDING
INFRASTRUCTURE HOSTAGE.
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING THAT WE
VOTED ON A INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
THAT WAS BIPARTISAN AND WE ARE
NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR IT UNLESS
YOU CUT THE SPENDING.
SOMEONE HAS GOT TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
>> Katie: THERE IS TOO MUCH
MONEY ON THE LINE.
>> Jesse: THEIR CLAIMANT ARMY.
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR A LITTLE ARMY.
AOC.
PAID ACTIVISTS TO FIGHT FOR THE
PROGRESSIVE WING OF THE PARTY.
THAT'S BIG.
WE HAVE BUREAUCRAT DAY CARE,
ELDERLY CARE, GOVERNMENT RUN
EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING IS FREE.
YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE IT AND ROCK
WITH IT.
THEY SLIPPED IN AMNESTY, GREEN
CARDS FOR SILICON VALLEY.
IT'S A LOT.
PLUS, THEY TRIGGERED WITH THE
BOTTOM LINE NUMBERS.
THEY TOOK 4 TRILLION AND COOKED
IT DOWN TO UNDER 2 TRILLION.
FOOLING AROUND WITH THE SUNSET
CLAUSES TO FOOL THE MODERATES.
I MUFFLED BY IT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE GAMES THEY
ARE PLAYING.
BIDEN IS AN OLD MAN, HE HAS BEEN
IN THE SENATE FOREVER.
HE KNOWS HOW LONG HE CAN WAIT TO
GET IT UNDER THE WIRE.
THEY WILL SLIP IT IN UNDER THE
WIRE AND THEY WILL GET SOMETHING
EVENTUALLY.
>> Katie: GREG, NOW THAT WE
HAVE LITTLE GREG, I AM SURE THAT
YOU ARE FOR CHILD CARE SPENDING.
>> Greg: FINALLY.
THE TOPIC IS THE FAR LEFT IS
THREATENING TO SINK THE BIDEN
AGENDA.
I THINK THE POPE IS NOT THAT
POWERFUL.
THIS POPE'S FAR LEFT, LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT.
I REFUSED TO FALL FOR THIS
BIFURCATION, THIS SCAM OF THE
SQUAD VERSUS JOE.
THAT'S ONLY BEING DONE TO MAKE
JOE APPEAR MORE MODERATE.
OH, MY GOD, LOOK AT THE SQUAD.
THEY ARE SO FAR LEFT.
THIS IS EXACTLY THE SAME FRAMING
THAT THEY DID WITH THE SPENDING
BILL.
$3.4 TRILLION.
OH, MY GOD.
MAYBE 1.8 DOESN'T LOOK SO BAD.
IT IS THE PARALLEL.
THE SQUAD IS THE 3.4 AND JOE IS
THE 1.8.
THEY APPEAR MODERATE.
WE ARE ALL GETTING SCREWED.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THEY STILL
HAVE THE ARMY AND THERE.
THAT'S ALMOST AS MUCH IS OUR
MILITARY.
INCREDIBLE.